hey guys over this past weekend we had
an omegle event where I was able to get
online and chat with you guys face to
face it was something that I've never
experienced before outside of like a
convention where I met people and I'm
really happy of the way it turned out
now I couldn't meet with everyone I
really wish I could have because I'm
just really proud of what you guys have
built this community just seeing people
face-to-face and being able to talk with
them has been just this heartwarming
experience I mean sincerely I heard some
really touching stories out of this and
I recorded about 10 hours of footage and
I was even on omegle for longer than I
was recording so I guess a total of 12
hours I was sitting around chatting with
people and again I wish I wish I could
have gotten everyone and if you were on
omegle and you never found me I am so
sorry I wish I could have been there but
hopefully I'll be able to do it again
you know I may not even record it but
because I did here is a little
compilation of some of the people that I
met
hi how's it going
I've been looking for you for so long I
have to be like I've seen you before my
friend oh my god oh my god god oh my god
oh my what's going on what happened oh
my god oh oh oh god don't work example
hi are you really yeah yeah I was
fooling you in the beginning I was out
of faking you out yeah let's going good
how are you a little monster there nice
you are you oh don't cry no no no cry
cry oh
oh hello little piggy no no little piggy
go home
I like that oh my gosh hello little
kadai and what would you like for
Christmas a deer any night I knew nice
to pay the ghost tab little kids in the
back cuz you're just the crazed Santa
but stabber
hello that's good I mean oh my god are
you okay can't hear anything there we go
I hear I hear I hear hi how's it going
hi are you doing bye uh-oh oh look at
the doggy how many people oh my god
hello yes you is it you you met mark
four times now so I'll show you what a
beauty really clear what it isn't really
Oh liar
oh is it really old who else would it be
you live I got my horses that's not true
come on that's not true
booth oh my god I don't cry does a
normal guy okay oh you're not I didn't
know that normally but quickly buddy you
okay
Nicole Nicole I know you're going to
watch this video later so I just wanted
to say that I love you very very much
oh can you do your your uh your your
dance your your dance party dance my dad
my dad's party this with me don't just
make me dance alone
yeah I just want to say I totally love
your videos and I'm watching it every
time with my girlfriend and we just want
to say you're the best let me taste them
you're not just a human being to meet
you're someone special that makes me
laugh and whenever I'm upset you always
say that way your hero but you're our
hero so I just want you to know that and
I want you to hold on to that so I'd
like to thank you I mean I seen your
drama life and that was emotional but
you come out of that and all you want to
do is entertain people and raise money
for charity and that's that's
respectable beyond so many levels
all the charity stuff you do it's just
great and it's incredible that you give
back to the community I just wanted to
say and thank you for all the chance
that you were done I mean like about
whatever like three days ago um have
hair that went about hopping on my back
you know don't hear it all cut off for
cancer research UK hey that's an
audience but thanks so much for doing
the cadre thanks for being an Aussie
feels good thanks for being you my
little brother and I will watch watched
you while we were moving and you really
helped us through a really rough time
and I just want to say like really I
just got into you because of her and
like I want to thank you so much for
like what you've done like you're so
inspirational and such a good person and
like I just want you to feel like you're
such a good person and you do the best
that you can like never feel that you
undermine any of us like we really
really appreciate it okay so that was
just a few of the people that I met no I
spent hours chatting with people and I
tried to break it up as much as I could
but if you didn't make it in the video
but you did see me and thanks anyway for
being there I really do appreciate your
support and sincerely thank you guys so
much I mean after the video I made
yesterday or not yesterday last week
that you all know about the right is the
fears fan-made
a game where I felt like I was losing
touch with you guys this really this
really helped you know I think it helped
me and I think it helped a lot of you
guys to really understand that I am I am
a real person you know I'm just one guy
in a in a room in front of a computer
talking but you guys are really what
make this community what it is and you
guys are what support are the cause is
that we believe in it and and that means
a lot to me yeah what you guys do means
a lot to me and seeing it right in front
of my eyes and face to face with you
guys who have been supporting me for so
long some people said that they were
here with me from the beginning you know
back when I had just a couple thousand
of subscribers and it means a lot to me
to know that it's still there it renewed
my confidence in what we're doing here
together and why I started this channel
in the first place so as we all know I'm
coming up on a million subscribers and I
got something big planned for that but
you know the number of subscribers that
we have doesn't really matter it's it's
what we do with them you know it's what
we do together as a community and what
we're building now and it's stronger
than it ever was but I really want you
guys to know that I do appreciate each
and every one of you I tried to make
sure that everyone I talked to on omegle
knew that I really cared
person-to-person and that I was just one
guy but together or something more you
know but that was it and I may do this
omegle thing in the future and I may do
a video of it I don't know just stay
tuned if you really want it let me know
and I'll try to get on omegle just to
talk with you guys again because I had a
lot of fun I wouldn't have done it if I
didn't have fun and it was just hours
and hours that I kept flying and go Wow
one more person one more person that's
how I ended up going many hours more
than I thought I was going to do you
know but it was all worth it thanks to
you guys so thank you so much for
watching
and thank you for being here on omegle
and as always I will see
in the next video bye-bye